hola que tal un cordial saludo a todas y
todos desde aquí desde el estudio 93 de
radio canadá en montreal me acompañan
hoy en estudio ruso valencia leonora
chapman y leonardo gimeno para
presentarles este castor cibernético de
el viernes 25 de mayo en vivo y en
directo por facebook live youtube y en
nuestro sitio internet un caluroso
saludo a todas ya todos en cualquier
lugar del mundo donde se encuentren
leonora russo leonardo bienvenida
bienvenidos pablo y hace calor y ya está
queriendo aunque esta semana durante las
mañanitas estaba un poco fresco
hoy vamos bien
la nevada allí
no no no no en una provincia del
atlántico te acuerdas del nuevo
brunswick pero una cantidad de nieve
simpático la nieve por lo menos 15 20
centímetros
5 grados más frío por la mañana me daba
la atención el cartelito que me mandaron
cuando hicieron en diciembre que empezó
a ser frío
molesto aquí en montreal
la fiesta que duele ese frío que uno
pasa terminó te duele ese bueno y asia
en cuyo uac 15 bajo cero
moscú 22 bajo cero no sé dónde en el
polo norte 24 ojos en montreal 32 van 0
el norte frío que moscú imagínate en
nuestros oyentes deben decirse como los
maltratan los tienes y costeados el frío
siempre siempre esperando para abordar
los programas y cualquier conversación
hace calor
no me digan que no extrañan un poco el
fresquito
pero no importa por ahí una pieza con un
poco de acondicionador me deja un
poquito mejor pero es igual frío y salir
y caminar el cuello
yo no sé si me encanta pero hace dos
semanas estaba en colombia y te lo juro
ni siquiera pensé
bueno antes de darle rienda suelta a
este castor cibernético tienen alguna
noticia hubo un tema inédito
interesantes y encontré esto en un
diario el cáncer infantil más común
podría ser prevenible
ya que bien y tiene que en realidad
tiene que ver con un caso muy puntual de
cáncer es un tipo de leucemia leucemia
perdón que es uno de los cáncer más
común en los niños
y este estudio de varias décadas si no
me equivoco dice que hay dos
posibilidades
hay dos digamos elementos que pueden
lanzar la probabilidad de este cáncer
uno es intrauterinos y unos
extrauterinos el interino todavía no se
puede corregir y el extractor y no tiene
que ver con la asepsia total black milk
exceso de piel
el exceso de que no toque que seque el
chupete que lavarlo con agua
oxigenada y después con agua hervida y
ponerlo en el refrigerador durante unas
cuantas horas para que ese tipo de
excesos provocan que el cuerpo de la
criatura en conjunto con lo otro
desarrolle una incapacidad para luchar
con cierta cantidad de defensas se le
eliminan las defensas hay otro aspecto
de esa otra consecuencia también de esa
de ese exceso
digamos exceso de uso de químicos que
justamente son las alergias
exactamente país donde la gente pasa 50
60 años
normal y después de un año para otro 45
no quiere que su hijo tenga alergia al
maní de la manía a partir de un año que
la tierra y que jueguen con los bichos
que tiene que la grasa del cuerpo el
cuerpo del niño debe generar su propio
cuerpo
yo nunca sufrí de ninguna alergia cuando
estuve cuando vivía en colombia ni en
los primeros años mozos y bueno llegó ya
43 años aquí de los cuales por lo menos
15 en los últimos 15 años donde he
desarrollado toda una serie de alergias
y de alimentos y en fin bueno yo siempre
fui ale toda la que me sentí más
propenso pero no lo desarrollaste antes
por la vida que llevaste o sea nada de
nada de ser limpito en una vez eso puede
haber [ __ ] la aparición de las
alergias
uno no dice que mantengan a la criatura
en un ambiente lleno de mugre
que el niño juegue en el piso que juegue
en la tierra ese tipo de cosas pueden
llegar a prevenir este tipo de cáncer la
forma como se crían los chicos en
latinoamérica y en muchos países del
tercer mundo no entonces es que hay
alguna estadística sobre los cánceres
desarrollados por los niños en los
países como canadá no les acepta y en el
tercer mundo no no me fijé si hay debe
haber de porque en realidad está esta
locura por la limpieza extrema es
bastante bastante presente en las
sociedades americanas y europeas europea
y hablando de niños a mí me sorprendió
un tema que vi un vídeo en columbia
británica un oso de 120 kilos que se
sube
a un árbol y resulta que el árbol empezó
a inclinarse y se subió y no podía bajar
se ha imposibilitado de bajarse y
acudieron los bomberos y estaba muy
nervioso
los bomberos empezaron a hablarle como
si fuera un niño a calmarlo y puedes
creer que el oso se calmó y pudieron
ponerle unas cuerdas y una tabla y
bajarlo y sirve cuando se lo baja y el
oso contento
se dejó hipnotizar digamos pero
increíble inglés y los bomberos no
llegaban se caía de ese árbol y
posiblemente pues se rompía no quiere
decir que el instinto animal más allá de
decir lo brutal que puede ser también
dios le habla
no le hables
sin funcionar eso no bueno que a veces
una de las cosas que tiene que ver desde
la historia los pitbull o de los perros
asesino entre comidas está comprobado
que
que ver con la educación que seguramente
lo trata como esclavo lo trata como si
fuera un objeto y ese tipo de cosas
tienes algo que es bueno y si tengo un
perro es mi es mi psiquiatra mi
consejero político
es un perdiguero dorado
lindos que eso es un corazón con cuatro
patas y es para los niños especialmente
y es una gallina con cuatro patas
es una señora
pero es muy muy miedoso pero muy
protectora sin tiempos y nada de una
inteligencia increíble
tiene toda serie de ritos que es otra
persona ha quedado tu vida tu vista y
desde que nació básicamente pero y esto
es justamente algo nuevo para mí porque
en la sim bolivia y en bolivia las casas
son tienen de sant cerradas y ti si
tienes un perro el profesor de afuera
tiene su casa tiene su espacio pero allí
yo dije bueno me proponen vivir con un
perro entonces bueno digo bueno en mi
modelo era ese entonces otra cosa a
vivir con un pie hay que sacarlo a
pasear a la mañana es un retroceso en la
evolución del ser humano porque hicimos
subido los dinosaurios
acabamos recogiendo el estiércol del
perro entonces bueno pero está bien
te obliga a caminar claro te obliga a
limpiar más seguido las américas y al
mismo tiempo te da convencional
yo siempre los molesto mis hijos y les
digo ojalá ustedes tres vinieran a
saludarme como viene a saludarme mi
perrita
esto es totalmente cierto así que y pues
es una gran es realmente algunas veces
hay reuniones de trabajo que son muy
tensas y aumentos de intensas
discusiones por ejemplo en el piso 22
aquí siempre me pregunto fuiste con el
perro
con el perro y todo el mundo claro
encontraría un acuerdo un punto en común
claro exacto
y claro es otra realidad porque he visto
también a los perros américa latina no y
realmente algunos llevan una vida más
que de perros no hay esa consideración
aquí hay leyes que prohíben el maltrato
hay leyes que responsabilizan a los
dueños hay que registrarlos la
municipalidad está más +11 está obligado
a ser más responsable y volvemos a lo de
siempre y gracias al clima entre
comillas el perro
en nuestras ciudades en argentina por
ejemplo es muy común ver pero sí hay
gatos callejeros por ejemplo que eso si
pasan el invierno afuera así en montreal
y bueno pues y se las arreglan para las
bandas se demasiado frío pues se
encuentran sus lugarcitos donde cerca
pegaditos a las casas donde hay
emanaciones de calor de una forma y
viven perfectamente afuera lo que me lo
cual no sería el caso de los perros se
morirían de frío lo que no todos lo que
es la que quería referir como tema que
me sorprende es que en australia están
construyendo la mayor red anti gatos
para proteger una área para proteger
justamente especies locales que están en
peligro de desaparición y estiman esto
ellos que los gatos domésticos y los
gatos silvestres pero
matan cada noche a un millón de pájaros
y eso que distinguen muchos gatos en
australia rojo claro claro pero me
imagino que es igual en las ciudades y
de hecho varios estudios demostrando que
los gatos son son felinos cazadores y
que causan estragos para las aves sobre
todo deja muy bien bueno a mí me llamó
la atención esta noticia de un franco o
mutar jens que se fue de viajes en
bicicleta en el 2016 y pasó 14 meses se
salió de recorrido inglaterra y malasia
y todo esto en bicicleta recorrió 18 mil
kilómetros y para él la mejor forma de
viajar si quieres conocer la gente si
quieres conocer su cultura si quieres
familiarizarte con esa cultura es la
bicicleta y no el tren no el bus o el
avión porque estando en bicicleta tienes
un contacto directo con la gente y bueno
siempre y cuando no andes por lugares
peligrosos si como en méxico
los ciclistas aparentemente asesinados
europeos un polaco y un polaco y un
sueco si no me equivoco o que comentar
es una tragedia porque además justamente
eso decían ellos recorren el mundo en el
mejor medio que es la bicicleta ya me
hace pensar a nuestro amigo argentino
damián lópez
de alaska hasta tierra hasta la tierra
del fuego en bicicleta y bueno vecinos y
va haciendo un informe cada vez que iba
llegando a un lugar durante durante tres
años los seguimos así de esta forma sí
entonces pues bien me pareció curioso
pues esta forma de viajar no en
bicicleta y éste frank con también se
ahora dice que quiere descubrir china
corea y japón en su propio mar lo que
quiera pues en asia y será también en
bicicleta entonces pues ya hablando de
japón y bicicletas
aquí en radio canadá en la sección
inglesa hay un camarada un periodista
que
mismo ha fabricado su bicicleta con
bambú y yo la he visto esta bicicleta
estacionada acá en el bicicletero como
digo yo sí sí sí sí la visualidad es
funcional y con este gap type con esta
cinta de electricista
si todas las intersecciones de su
bicicleta en bambú pero muy muy muy bien
hecha y bueno pese con algunos elementos
más modernos mercado es la nueva
industria que decían de construcción de
bicicletas en europa las de bambú están
teniendo un éxito muy grande de ser
ligeras
sí sí seguro y son muy baratas a
comparación de las que ahora ahora
cuesta mucho dinero una visita que
acabemos con el bambú entonces
lo último que digo es que hay un como
que el último que vas a decir sobre los
y que todo el programa está por delante
justamente encontraron no sé si vieron
ustedes
en instagram en estas cuentas facebook
que encontraron en una calle de
marruecos una bicicleta bixi de montreal
y llegó lejos como hizo esa persona para
llevarlas a bicicleta en el aeropuerto
porque además tiene la marca oficial de
la municipalidad de montreal la recall
para registrarte tienes que tener
tarjeta de crédito y si la pierdes te
des cuenta como mil dólares
si llego a llamar pero gracias a todo
esto mi querido leonardo tenemos
comentarios y alguien que esté viendo en
él si la envida dice arriba amigos darse
y nada escuché en la escucha y después
viví dice pons y juan carlos miranda tu
arte saludos a todos desde chile
así que saludos a todos ellos que están
sintonizando y nuestra colega
paloma martínez también está mirando a
la escucha de la marina
si es un plato de piedra caramba y el
méxico es la hora de que rojo serán pues
que es mejor un poco en tequila siempre
viene bien
me gusta
el pp no no era pp me voy a tomar nota y
restaurante obrero en buenos aires en
pleno centro de buenos aires de los años
50 sigue abierto es barato y es rico
supongo yo creo que sí es una
institución es un equipo bueno tenemos
comentarios también acá en nuestros que
represados así que vamos a
a pasar a dar lectura a leonardo ya veo
que están listos canadá y su plan de
inmigración de 2018 luís guerra dice
actualmente vive en eeuu y mi esposo y
yo somos graduados universitarios
tenemos dos hijos 16 y 8 acá es
invivible deseamos ir a canadá pero nos
da temor la inmigración canadiense nos
entregue al dice que debe ser en la
institución es la inmigración y la
comisión de inmigración y refugiados de
canadá y nos regresan a nuestro país
donde yo vengo huyendo de las amenazas
de muerte por mi profesión soy abogado
dice en este punto no encuentro una
arista en la política inmigratoria de
canadá para qué
yo me pueda acoger dice cuál es el
comentario cuál es nuestro comentario
tengo una voz fuerte y habilidades de
locución también ahora bueno
lamentablemente la manera es consultando
a los expertos en inmigración nosotros
al sitio mismo de inmigración canadá que
además hay información en español
también si a veces también eligiendo no
sé si las provincias tienen distintos
también hay información por pro por
provincia que por ahí para niños elena
les prefiere ir a alguna provincia algo
forma también puede funcionar muy bien
ahora tengo un comentario acá sobre
canadá preocupado por la situación en
nicaragua y escribe veros cara y dice en
nicaragua hay una dictadura ningún
gobierno tiene derecho de mandar a
masacrar a la población esto no puede
permitirse en ningún país del mundo en
pleno siglo 21
un comentario un poco extenso porque
vale la pena leer ese sobre las
elecciones en venezuela nicolás maduro
salió victorioso en venezuela pero sus
adversarios reclamaron nuevas elecciones
inicio barra les dice que chile y
colombia lideran lista con mayor
abstencionismo electoral no alcanzan al
50% chile dice él por ejemplo lidera una
vista de 10 países donde menos la gente
acude a las urnas electorales en los
días de elecciones cuya participación
electoral en los pasados comicios fue de
46.7 por ciento en la elección de
sebastián piñera en 2017 y 49.36 por
ciento con michelle bachelet en 2013
mientras tanto colombia se posiciona de
número 6 en la lista de países con mayor
abstención electoral en voto voluntario
país que presentó un 40 punto 65 por
ciento de participación en la primera
vuelta y un 47.97 una segunda vuelta en
la elección de juan manuel santos en
el vice decano de la escuela de política
y relaciones internacionales de la
universidad sergio arboleda en colombia
freddy barreros destacó en una
entrevista concedida que desde hace
décadas se viene hablando de una crisis
de la representación política que tienen
como señales en alto grado de
desafección por parte de los ciudadanos
de los partidos entonces dice dionisio
barrales en venezuela- vota un 48 por
ciento del padrón electoral no hay
participación están todos comprados y es
una conspiración de millones de
venezolanos en chile vota el 46% del
patrón electoral y piñera es presidente
participan todos los sectores y no hay
ningún problema no cuadra dice el muy
bien entonces 0 comentario de dionisio
varales sobre las asas o está sobre cómo
se cuantifica la participación y como
canadá dice que no es democrática y como
le hablando hablando de resultados
electorales también orden de democracias
lo curioso también es por ejemplo eeuu
donde un presidente no es el más votado
por la población y es elegido presidente
no es
también son cosas que yo no tienen en
cuenta y había otros análisis había
rumores de analistas que decían que ni
siquiera quería salir presidente que se
presentó solo por porque me puedo
presentar y por qué puedo hacerlo y
ahora les está gustando 33 millones de
votos menos creo que se levantó pero eso
es algo que es difícil tiene referente
entonces es donde está la lógica como
dice claramente de onís y ojalá fuera
solamente eso no porque es eeuu se
autonombra del vigilante o el que se
encarga de asegurarse que haya
democracia por todas partes que es raro
que es muy raro misión militar
canadiense en siria una decisión
equivocada norma dice buenas noches
tengo un amigo soldado canadiense y me
dice que ellos quieren regresar a canadá
a ver sus familias que ya tienen más de
23 meses en alepo siria las autoridades
canadienses ya deben retirar a sus
soldados por una cuestión de salud
mental hay soldados que han fallecido
emboscadas esto se debe saber ayúdenlos
a volver a sus hogares por favor es un
comentario de norma con respecto a los
soldados que se encuentran a los
soldados canadienses que se encuentran
actualmente en siria yo aquí tengo otro
comentario médico canadiense herido en
gasa todo pide explicaciones a israel di
bernardo surf levi surf levi en realidad
no hay un es ese r
así que schürrle bitch dice preguntó qué
hacía un médico que estaba al alcance de
una bala en un acto de provocación en la
frontera las manifestaciones con más de
40.000 participantes no son pacíficas
según el propio jamás lo dicen sus
dirigentes terroristas lo reconocen en
entrevistas de las cadenas árabes no es
pacífica desde el momento que intenta
romper las vallas fronterizas para
penetrar en israel y realizar actos
terroristas sobre la población civil no
es pacífica desde el momento que
remontan barriletes para provocar
incendios en los poblados y en los
cultivos no es pacífica quien lleva
cócteles molotov y armas pónganse en
lugar de un recluta de apenas 18 años
que se ve amenazado por una tour
descontrolada y aún están difíciles
circunstancias que mantienen la calma y
sólo disparan a terroristas la propia
organización reconoce que más de los 60
muertos 52 pertenecían al comando
terrorista hamas pero como los europeos
saben que ya no es políticamente
correcto declararse como antisemitas
ahora tienen la excusa de practicarla
siendo anti israel que este es un
mensaje de bernardo surf levi con
respecto a médico canadiense herido en
gasa trudeau pide explicaciones israel y
ahora tengo acá un comentario
interesante porque sobre el castor
cibernético del 18 19 y 20 de mayo y red
escribe raúl alcalá
y dice buenas noches estimados amigos
del castor cibernético como están siglos
sin escribirse la venezuela creó siglos
sin escribirles pero hoy mientras los
estoy escuchando no pude resistir el
impulso de escribir mira cómo será
y luego no solo para reportar la
audición sino también para comunicarles
mi agrado por la espontaneidad con la
que interactúan durante sus
transmisiones me parece también
importante que se siga ampliando la
difusión de misas en español haya en
canadá los escucho desde la ciudad de
acarigua en el estado portuguesa en
venezuela saludo
y canadá salí solía hacerlo pero no sé
si ahora pero cuando chequeo los canales
que a veces hay por lo menos dos o tres
lugares donde están las cadenas
televisivas religiosas que esa visión
por ejemplo es aire no necesita salir a
la nieve o al calor y está muy bien
claro para que para la gente que no
puede acudir a esa cosa si este este fin
de semana bueno con el castor de la
semana pasada es momento dado se me
olvidó se me olvidó ir a copiar y a
transcribir estos correos que el mensaje
es más bien que nos envió uno de
nuestros oyentes que se llama marc
harris y márkaris decía que me hablaba
del fantasma de sackville dice
ahora en américa latina está el fantasma
de sackville que retransmite por la onda
corta
este programa entonces dice que hay se
puede radio chilena creo que es exacto
en la red de chile chile nosotros a
veces es la radio en chile que transmite
difunde nuestro programa exacto si
entonces pues decía que que les gusta
mucho justamente este ambiente que hemos
creado digamos con este programa y que
lo retransmiten para mantener la onda
corta viva y al mismo tiempo para
mantener vivo al castor cibernético en
la onda corta de un ambiente espontáneo
relajado y sin fútbol
[Aplausos]
ya quiere hablar de si estamos con un
partido a la misma hora y podemos ir
narrando los en distintas lenguas y por
lo de fondo
bueno para variar un poquitito vamos a
seguir más tarde con nuestros mensajes
pero vamos a alternar con los temas que
vamos a destacar esta semana en este
castor cibernético y tú león ahora nos
hablas de la práctica del ayuno para
vivir más y con salud una práctica que
yo nunca he practicado yo un poquito se
trata del ayuno que es una práctica
milenaria dicen que existe desde que
existe el ser humano y los animales la
practican y los seres humanos y ese hay
datos por ejemplo se sabe que en los
últimos 150 años la esperanza de vida de
los canadienses
de 40 a 80 años el tema es que esos años
de más que uno está ganando no se viven
a veces en buena salud el final el medio
trágico regis exacto entonces estás
enfermo tienes problemas y entonces él
está el doctor martín you know que es
director de prevención en el instituto
del corazón de montreal que él dice que
para remediar esa situación de no estar
de no pasar esos años enfermo
la clave es prevenir el desarrollo de
enfermedades y él por supuesto habla de
algo que todo el mundo sabe es decir
para prevenir el envejecimiento y mal
tener cuidado con las enfermedades
cardiovasculares diabetes tipo 2 tipos
de cáncer etcétera etcétera por el lanza
una nueva idea que está tomando cada vez
más el camino amplitud y es que hay otro
factor de protección de esa vejez que es
mucho menos conocido que es justamente
en red una reducción de la cantidad de
calorías y va más allá del hecho de
reducir calorías para perder peso que
además él dice advierte
para perder peso no lo haga porque igual
lo va a aumentar de vuelta duran apenas
termine el ano pcc balanza sobre el
habla de ayunar para rejuvenecer las
células y el aquí dice que esta es una
de las claves para vivir más tiempo en
buena salud y él lo voy a leer esto
porque es medio médico la cosa dice
durante un ayuno nuestro cuerpo destruye
sus componentes de forma coordinada por
ejemplo parte de los músculos parte del
hígado a parte del sistema inmune
etcétera etcétera también destruye cada
parte de cada célula y esto se llama
autofagia luego dice al usar se usa el
ayuno como fuente de energía y cuando
comes de nuevo todo se reconstruye
nuevamente entonces durante un ayuno el
cuerpo tiende a destruir las células
dañadas antes que las células sanas y
esto nos lleva a hablar de otro tema
fundamental que él también destaca que
es el tratamiento de una persona que
tiene cáncer con quimioterapia y lo que
él dice que el ayuno mitiga los efectos
de la
y terapia se ha demostrado que dice
ayuda a resistir mejor los efectos
secundarios de la quimioterapia y que
después de realizar estudios en ratones
sometidos a tratamiento contra el cáncer
descubrieron que los roedores en ayunas
estaban más saludables que los otros y
el explica esto diciendo que las células
cancerosas son más vulnerables a la
quimioterapia y cuando el cuerpo se ve
privado de carbohidratos las células
sanas logran usar lípidos como fuente
alternativa de energía en cuanto a las
células cancerosas no tienen esta
capacidad y por lo tanto se debilitan y
finalmente digo sólo esto en humanos los
estudios clínicos han demostrado que el
ayuno puede disminuir los efectos
secundarios de la quimioterapia pero aún
no ha mostrado sus efectos sobre los
tumores esta es otra investigación
yo conozco he estado leyendo sobre gente
que porque hay un punto donde
la ciencia empieza a darse cuenta que el
modo en que el ser humano se alimenta
también tiene una correlación importante
con las distintas enfermedades punto
gente con el cáncer para tener una dieta
saludable para evitar el cáncer y cuando
tiene uno tiene cáncer que ahora
dependiendo del momento en que se lo
detecta alcanza son curables hay un
montón de tipos de cáncer que son
curables una de las maneras yo le
escuchaba un médico que habla sobre todo
con respecto a las dietas anti cáncer es
llamar henry henry yo ayer el médico
francés y él decía que es súper
interesante el hecho de mejorar la dieta
para evitarlo y cuando uno tiene antes
de la quimioterapia hacer hacer al menos
18 horas el cuerpo empieza ese proceso
también lo describe y debilita el tumor
entonces es como si digamos no está
probado científicamente pero debilita a
las células cancerosas exacto entonces
la quimioterapia es mejor
hace mucho mejor efecto que si no lo
hiciera
esto pueden buscar en youtube la terapia
va a afectar más a las células enfermas
no digo sin más en ayunas no es que las
enfermeras
células enfermas porque están más
débiles en ese momento entonces la
quimioterapia actúa con mayor eficacia y
después agua no y aquí en el artículo
hay como tres tipos de ayuno el que
menciona el doctor y uno de montreal y
dice ayuno intermitente alimentación
restringida en el tiempo y ayuno
periódico ya hay una definición de cada
uno de ellos y que en general se pueden
hacer porque son de muy corta duración
sin recurrir a los médicos mal no te va
a ser corta duración- quiere decir
cuánto pero por ejemplo está la fórmula
5 o 2 en siete días
cincodías com es normal y dos días es un
ayuno por semana que eso te limpia el
organismo una kilómetro significa no
comer nada no necesariamente hay un
ayuno intermitente ayuda además hay otro
tipo de ayuno que vos puedes por ejemplo
durante tres días limitarte es sólo
grasas buenas grasas limitarte por
ejemplo aceitunas y ya a boca a boca al
abogado aguacates aguas altas y como
cena y en el desayuno pues tienes nueces
entonces pues
es pura proteína vegetal nada más y se
hace fácilmente una limpieza increíble
del organismo entonces las células se
van renovando también esa es la idea si
justamente había otra otra otra tesis
otro estudio que mostraba que después de
un largo periodo de no comer como de 7 a
10 días si me acuerdo bien había el
sistema que se produce lo que se llama
un reboot si existe la css y eliminando
pues lo nocivo que a veces acumulado en
el cuerpo y hay unos completos de 20
días el circuito se apaga necesita el
comentario del procesado aquí josé julio
gonzález edorta dice saludos desde las
islas canarias
ya venir las canarias una amiga de islas
canarias que estuvo de paseo por acá por
monte hacia la radio guiniguada
en las canarias que ella viene de
mallorca mi amiga bueno grupo tu nos
hablan de periodistas aquí en canadá que
denuncian el centro de entrenamiento de
la ultraderecha pues justamente hay un
grupo estamos aquí tomar estamos que ve
que ser una dirección es quebrada y
quebec mira bastante y de una forma es
un eco de lo que pasa también europa y
han surgido en los últimos años aunque
esto data de mucho tiempo hasta los
tiempos de wii y xvii antes en que hay
grupos que tienen una ideología anti
inmigrante una ideología supremacista
blanca una ideología de ultraderecha en
la que por ejemplo dirán el eslogan que
tienen de ellos por ejemplo frente a la
pobreza los indigentes en montreal
organizan dan comida decir tuvo un uso
jean paul es otro todo para nosotros y
nada
los demás y justamente una de las
expresiones más más brutales diríamos de
esta ideología xenófoba es esta noción
de ley que beck pole que ve cuál es como
la francia para los franceses entonces
un grupo de esta naturaleza invadió esta
semana los locales de un medio y medio
de comunicación y que se llama vice y
entraron llevando máscaras con el color
de la bandera de quebec y pues dejaron
dejaron una serie de un premio al
periodista que cubre justamente las
actividades de ese tipo de grupos que se
llaman atalante y los hijos de audouin
que salen a las calles a supuestamente
vigilar y que no les pase nada a nadie
supuestamente pero que al fondo ellos
plantean una propuesta que se llama la
de migración que he puesto la
inmigración la generación es decir la
básicamente que los que no son de raíz
francófona que se remonta el siglo 16
pues regresen entre comillas a sus cosas
para esos países y ese es una canción
vieja claro y hay trillada por acá sí y
esto que pasa que supuestamente pasa al
exterior que son esos movimientos
los pequeños ultra derechistas etcétera
pero lo que pasa es que hay un eco por
ejemplo con conceptos centrales dentro
la forma de entender que ve que es por
ejemplo esta categoría que se llama la
sociedad de aquí y la sociedad de
acogida que da por sentado de que hay
primero una sociedad homogénea que es la
que te acoge pero por ejemplo no se toma
en cuenta o no se dice por ejemplo qué
parte de esa sociedad son también otros
inmigrantes que están pagando sus
impuestos que están también sirviendo
para jose que no hay esa hemos como gen
edad la única la única sociedad sólida
que la única sociedad de acogida
realmente cierta fueron los otros ni
genas entonces ahí está entonces era
importante lo que pasó también fue que
la federación procesada terroristas de
quebec denunció este acto como un acto
de amedrentamiento como un acto que pone
en riesgo la libertad de prensa y decían
bueno si ahora van a sus puestos de
trabajo qué va a pasar después el propio
primer ministro de la provincia de
québec circular también expresó su
alarma ante este tipo de gestos
y lo irónico es que la policía dice que
como no hubo daño material entonces que
no es mi padre que no lo que hicieron
aparte de entrar al local que es una
manera por supuesto de demostrar algo al
interior le dieron un supuesto premio al
periodista si sigue que sobre estos
temas como es el periodismo el
periodismo basura justamente porque
escribía entre otras cosas justamente y
cuáles son las describía cómo funciona
estos grupos en quebec y eso es esta
revista vice tiene es una revista que
también hace periodismo de investigación
en otras provincias canadienses como en
alberta y ellos fueron estos periodistas
los que hicieron una investigación sobre
la infiltración de estos grupos de
extrema derecha para captar nuevos
miembros en organismos que trabajan con
gente por ejemplo con problemas de
drogas y que acuden a esos organismos en
busca de ayuda entonces esto también fue
denunciado por vice en alberta y es un
fenómeno bastante fuerte que se está
estos grupos están creciendo y tienen
muchas maneras de infield de infiltrarse
para lograr traer más gente y esa era la
denuncia de baix también si bueno y esto
pues quizá también haya partidos
políticos aquí en quebec que de cierta
forma abran la puerta para actitudes
como esa veamos
recientemente françois lengua que es el
jefe de la coalición a venir quebec que
se pronunció y que presentó su su
política para tratar a electoral y para
la inmigración su punto de vista sobre
la inmigración en la que decía que los
inmigrantes que
o se integren o sea y que no hable en
francés que no se busquen un empleo o
sea cuando en general sólo hacerlo es lo
que hacen acá no pero él dice aquel que
no lo haga entonces que canadá tiene que
enviarlo a otro lugar de día sabe
sonreír porque había un artículo que
salió en uno de los diarios de un
periodista que decía yo estoy de acuerdo
con él dice por el que la cuestión del
francés tienen que hacerles pasar el
test pero yo creo que tienen que
hacérselo pasar a todos los que vick en
ses porque sabemos que el 40 por ciento
de los quebequenses tienen problemas con
el francés pero también se ignora o deja
de lado por ejemplo que el inglés es una
lengua que está aquí desde hace siglos
que es también una lengua una lengua que
hace parte central de la historia de
quebec sin hablar de las lenguas
indígenas o sea como entonces es
problemático es esta noción de patria de
nación siempre ha tenido problemas sí y
no sólo aquí claro por todos lados hay
algún comentario de un comentario
solamente los saludos que vemos
he hecho recién y nada más nada más que
eso ahora tú querías pronunciarse sobre
lo que estábamos comiendo loro no no no
no
entonces yo es por mi parte invitó a
nuestros oyentes a que escuchen una
entrevista que hice con una arqueóloga
anglo mexicana que está presentando en
este momento una exposición en el museo
de antropología de la universidad de
columbia británica en vancouver una
exposición que se titula artes de
resistencia la política y el pasado en
latinoamérica
esta exposición comenzó el 17 de mayo y
será presentada en el museo de
antropología de la universidad de
columbia británica en vancouver hasta el
8 de octubre y lo particular de esta
exposición de arte de resistencia es que
ella
la mayoría de los dibujos y obras que se
están presentando en esta exposición son
contemporáneas contemporáneas pero con
una alusión al pasado como por ejemplo
hay una obra de un par de jóvenes
mexicanos que se llama el codex
ayotzinapa entonces quiere decir
utilizan los códecs aztecas para
representar una realidad actual para
representar en este caso la mente se
refiere a los estudiantes
entonces ese dibujo es justamente para
denunciar la desaparición de los 43
estudiantes en china para iu
pero los dibujos son dibujos del corte
los códecs aztecas entonces pues hay esa
relación antes entre el pasado y el
presente para contar la historia y la
gran parte de todos de todas las obras
que se están presentando en esta
exposición tienen esa relación que me
parece muy interesante
y cuando se establecen paralelos
políticos ahí
no sólo en no solo en méxico porque
tienen obras que vienen de chile perú
ecuador el salvador y guatemala entonces
pues está bien amplia la la arqueóloga
se llama laura osorio son ops y ella
pues presenta es la curadora de la
exposición y fue la que escogió todas
estas obras que se presentan en esa
exposición y los invitamos a que
escuchen esa entrevista y
desafortunadamente que estamos en el
salón y se nos está olvidando en la
semana próxima el 31 el jueves el
programa no será el viernes será el
jueves 31 de mayo el programa se va a
hacer en directo desde el salón de la
inmigración de quebec estuvimos el año
pasado allá este año vamos a estar
nuevamente allí
y ojo también que se va a comenzar a las
once y media y no a las doce y cuarto
como lo ve igual vamos a ir mandando
mensajes para hacerles acordar de esto
bueno y eso fue todo por hoy no nos
podemos despedir sin decirle adiós a los
espías
[Música]
desde entonces